winning a major requires three things it
requires incredible unbelievable play it
requires determination you tweeted I
will not give up till a win a mother in
nature and it requires a lot of luck we
are left with immortals vs. gambit it is
the surprise major two teams that didn't
stand a chance according to most of the
experts at the start of this on October
12 2016 soos left natus vincere a team
he'd been a part of since 2012 it taught
him very much they did it behind his
back
Zeus had helped make Navi the powerhouse
it was in csgo but after a string of
poor performances his team replaced him
with a rising star simple he is one of
the truth prodigies that we've had in
counter-strike Zeus was benched in
August but he knew it was coming
in July he tweeted I am NOT going to
give up before I win a [__]
major Zeus joined gambit eSports
alongside young star Hobbit he's got two
kills already wrapped over top he's
gonna go for yam human body bags and
he's got them all
I am a fan Zeus became the team's
captain giving gambit eSports the
coordination they needed to shine maybe
talking about the resurgence of tactical
counter-strike and the importance of
in-game leaders in Zeus hasn't been
slouching in the practice apartment
either gambit used that coordination to
bring in some impressive results what a
performance from them upsetting so many
teams all the way through and like you
say building for the major I'm impressed
this team is very exciting to watch
in January of 2017 gambit punched their
ticket to the crack of major by beating
the likes of north 16 to 8 at the end
God sent 69 in favor of gambit
and faze clan the loss route 16 to 14
they make it to the Fox Theater gambit
gave me become legends but the odds were
against them in Krakov analysts had
Astralis and sk favor to meet in the
grand finals no one predicted gambit to
make it I defy anyone online right now
to tell me honestly including our
analysts that they predicted this game
but gambit started hot sweeping aside
mousesports 16 to 10 victory for gambit
in their first match of the major they
knocked down g2 16 to 6 as gambit take
down g2 on hat finally gambit dominated
hometown heroes virtus Pro 16 to 11 to
make it out of their group undefeated
gambit despite virtus Pro being at home
take pole position into the playoffs
their first bracket match was against
fnatic the team that eliminated them
from the Atlanta major all of my
stepbrothers shot in the back
but gambit broke them - OH
to the semi-finals beautiful stuff from
them come
pretty common stripe major champions
Astralis or up next this is the biggest
test maybe for gambit of their career
this team a stralla
the clear favorites we're looking to end
gambits run at 3rd to 4th
but gambit one
buoyed by incredible play in spectacular
coordination gambit broke down the Danes
two-to-one securing a spot in the grand
finals well with immortals vs. gambit it
is the surprise major immortals drew
first blood taking cobble 16 to 4 after
a decisive and brutal tee side but
gambit came back swinging on train
turning the tide with a 16 to 11 win it
all came down to one final map inferno
ladies and gentlemen let's make some
noise
gambit started strong going up 9 to 1 on
the back of strong CT side play but
immortals were looking to rally in the
11th round
they brought gambit down to just doja
and a very low health zeus and took up
position on a site would he have the
options to retake this save the AWP Jews
picks that up Lucas and steal his
stacked up in back corner of Pitt the
Brazilians were set to both defend the
site and survive the bombs blast but
dosha was not looking to take the site
back he was looking to break immortals
[Applause]
The Immortals won the round
but doja won the war Lucas and Steel's
deaths crippled immortals economy
leaving steel stuck on Agra Lille and
Lucas one with zero utility in the next
round doges three hundred and fifty
thousand dollar grenade halted immortals
come back and put gambit and Zeus on
track to win the major but immortals
started their CT side strong winning
four straight rounds bringing the score
11 to 8 gambit is contacted right to the
second off he's got to be four zero but
the immortals could not quite make up
for their abysmal first half their play
was good but gambits was magnificent
[Applause]
maybe it was fate maybe it was just
insane luck but it was Zeus who picked
up the final major winning kill
[Applause]
it was Zeus who more than a year before
stated that he was going to win a
[__] major it was Zeus who led
a down on its luck team to the biggest
title in counter-strike the pgl major
right now comes to an end with the
confetti raining down on gambit eSports
the champions of this particular major
the first Ukrainian the first Russian
and the first Kazakhstan class of win a
major in csgo history maximum incredible
scenes
where are they now well right after the
major Zeus left his team in the dust and
went back to na'vi turns out lightning
does indeed strike twice with Zeus
gambit still has a spot at the next
major but has struggled to show the
kinds of results they put up while Zeus
was around first pro have just knocked
the major champions out of epicenter the
first team eliminated meanwhile Zeus is
Navi is doing just as poorly as it did
before he came on board it's a sad story
but gambit still has their title and
they still have doshas legendary grenade
and mortalized
as one perfect moment one perfect play
that encapsulated everything that was
special about gambits major run the
determination the ingenuity the magic
thanks for watching if you want more
great content be sure to hit that
subscribe button
[Music]